thank you
[Music]
there is a new Little Mermaid coming out
woohoo
I hate change
I don't like progress of any type what
are you referring to racial things oh
you guys aren't gonna like this here we
go
Disney 100.
who's it playing it is playing 100th
anniversary is the volume up the volume
is not up it's not on at all
there's there there it is yeah oh I see
a fish let's see fishies
oh that music
is insane though man
CGI is insane dude thank you
so I I missed a 2d
I think that's the whole point of this
this is the three the real right yeah
you know they've been doing live action
for all the Disney classics
all the music
well played already because we're gonna
get a takedown all right if we uh yeah
we gotta talk like like this but we're
talking over it so it's okay don't worry
what do you guys think of the rain today
dude they should come out with little
Little Mermaid the ride and then we
could go through like that
yeah
they might have just closed it yeah sure
they used to have it bad singing huh or
good okay really good it sounds really
good yeah I want to see her uses her
thinking about you know you know what I
mean yo she better have some clamshell
[ __ ] titties oh I heard that whoa we
better see him no by the way how big
should titties be
and she and she had clamshell titties
maybe it's a clamshell bra oh this is
like young Little Mermaid huh is that
what it is
bra is it like a prequel or something
maybe we should just focus on the
trailer
but anyway
that looks like Mary J blige's daughter
oh she looks beautiful yeah but don't
say that she's underage
like a beautiful like a beautiful thing
they really did it yeah she sounds
beautiful boy what is she from she's a
real person real person I think her name
is Halle Bailey yeah what is she from
she's actually the singer oh she's a
real like uh artist so what are you guys
thoughts on how her voice is great the
original Ariel was a white lady the
ruining Ariel oh my God Steve I didn't
even recognize she was black I don't see
color yeah we don't see color at this
channel I don't see color here of course
Steve you would choose this article yeah
creating all sorts yeah I chose this
Chris ruined the surprise before the
video was she was she really meant to be
white in the first one
like the extra mile to make every
character black now
all right they're ones are probably
walking coin broke because of it but
they've already but they've already like
announced it like that she was gonna
play Little Mermaid way back and there
was like a whole really oh they had a
whole problem with it because they were
trying to probably covered it too yeah I
mean you know what the real problem is I
don't care if she was black or Asian
she's not a [ __ ] redhead she needs to
be a redhead yeah
I want flaming hot Cheeto red okay
that's fair calm down the realistic
version
okay okay I'll I'll have to the screen
brightness was a little low dude hey hey
this is a [ __ ] HP Envy this thing's
barely two hundred dollars
where's the retina display yeah we
watched it on an Apple I'm not gonna
watch this [ __ ] at home good luck with
that you know what I don't like about
this
it's not white that's what I was trying
the part's not white yeah that's what
Mike that's what my character's going
for I don't even know did you did you
like comments did you like Doctor
Doolittle with Eddie Murphy Oh I loved
it you know that was originally a white
guy you don't say
he didn't like the Robert Downey hey you
know who else was white The Nutty
Professor dude
I don't know yeah 90 Professor was white
originally too people don't people don't
like that she's black I honestly am not
sure but I'm having a lot of fun with it
or the trailer but after the trailer it
was good it's been getting a lot of love
for sure did that really happen bro I
didn't even know this movie existed
until you told us about it today really
yeah I didn't know I never heard of the
new Little Mermaid never heard of it oh
yeah bro it's a uh well yeah that was
that was the whole thing because she was
gonna be I was gonna play by a black
woman but then even now like seeing it
like just it just looks beautiful just
the way it was like the the CGI kills it
she kills it it just looks incredible
she sounds like she's [ __ ] on money
dude I just wanted to see flounder up
close but they didn't show that so
fonder apparently my favorite is played
by Aquafina oh cool
shut the [ __ ] up
and Sebastian who's gonna be Sebastian
Aquafina yeah no I feel like they took
out one of those characters really yeah
no no wait I was the takeaways I think
it is the uh uh Sebastian I know I was
looking at this
is in this movie I was looking at this
during lunch she's Prince Eric she is
no she is um she is [ __ ] Davey digs
that Sebastian yeah
yeah
she's really Scuttle that's a good
Scuttle yeah oh the yeah yeah who's
flounder yeah Jacob Tremblay how do I
know that name oh who's Ursula yeah
who's Ursula Ursula I'm the name Jacob
Tremblay he's an oh he was in the movie
room that's right he was in the movie
room with Brie Larson he was the kid
oh yeah I've heard of him no Ursula
her voice is Robin in the DC Universe or
whatever that's what it said oh that's
solid yeah so so Melissa McCarthy is
going to probably be tripping and
falling and bumping into all kinds of
[ __ ] down there
stubbing her toe yeah you know what's
crazy like when people I mean when like
all these things get redone and there's
like different ethnicities whatever I
didn't give a [ __ ] or share one bit
but [ __ ] made Batman Ben Affleck from
a white one white guy to another white
guy I'm like what the [ __ ] and then to
Robert Patton said I'm like it has to
fit yeah yeah that's when Keaton got
Batman and the 89 I mean dude everyone
gets pissed about all this [ __ ] Robert
Patterson was pretty good as Batman
though he was solid I liked him better
than Ben Affleck I thought he was kind
of a whiny little [ __ ] boy I thought he
was a little bit of a [ __ ] boy yeah I
like it though I like the dark spots
around his eyes howdy bro yeah I didn't
like patents in as much do you think
that's exactly why is it people are not
offended when they localize a movie and
they just make all the Asian people wait
like which one infernal Affairs because
in America and that's okay yeah yeah I'm
actually I grew up with that
see whitewash [ __ ] I'm mad
watching a Samurai movie and I'm like
where are the white ninjas like what the
[ __ ] is this the white guy that's gonna
come to [ __ ] the princess and save the
day who am I rooting for
when I watch a Vietnam War movie I'm
like where's the [ __ ] curly-haired
Jew guy with a buff muscles oh yeah
Rambo where's he at where's the hero
yeah where's the Savior who are all
these stun guys and why do they have
lines
nothing we didn't learn about Tom
Cruise's Last Samurai in history
oh my God it's so dumb yeah and I'm just
like this is so stupid what's going on
here didn't they remake Pinocchio too do
they maybe just watch this again what'd
you think I thought it was okay just
like I think all the live actions are
it's all right I'm like Beauty and the
Beast but I'll give it to Tom Hanks
because Tom Hanks is Tom Hanks he plays
Geppetto did you guys either do a black
Superman with um Aegis what I don't know
um Akon Rockies Michael B Jordan Michael
B oh that's kind of cool he can do
anything HBO's produce but he's also
like all the time he can be in he's
always pouty too that's kind of cool
though he's gonna be in Marvel Universe
and DC I guess oh wow well Superman is
oh well he was in Fantastic Four
nobody's gonna [ __ ] about that either
that's true but that was that wasn't in
the MCU specifically yeah true I think
also people forget that when things are
remade like this it's not made for
[ __ ] old guys like us yeah wait for
the [ __ ] new kids the funniest thing
though when you got a bunch of Life 30
year old dudes going like oh Little
Mermaids ruin now that's what was the
worst dude they're just trying to sell
you the same thing you [ __ ] bought
yeah but also about Little Mermaid too
it's like I guess so much of it is her
ability to sing well and she does have a
really good voice so I feel like yeah
that's a good thing you guys heard of
the new Quantum Leap right so I was
watching football the other night
remember Quantum League no it's an Asian
dude no it's Asian right so terrible and
Asians are pissed because they're
getting all the calculations wrong
this is kind of accurate who's the Asia
Guy I don't know his name but I just saw
a trailer I was watching football and I
was like Blue's Clues that Filipino
Blues Clues guy oh they get the singer
from Germany his action debuted
yeah yeah get that guy in there you know
what they did do in the new Pinocchio is
they recast the Fairy Godmother and she
was black
[Laughter]
have you ever heard her acapella [ __ ] on
YouTube she's great it's [ __ ] insane
she fell into the shadow of her
brother's porn tent oh
I worshiped Brandy even more after
punked remember when she got her uh
raging out yeah they punked her and her
brother and they acted like something
happened in their car and she was so
sweet she was like please no like she
didn't get pissed at all she's very
lucky and I was like now sealed and she
really does like defend her brother yo
she's like a dope like sibling like I'm
I got my brother's back what's up like
even when they did like verses and he
was singing I mean awful but you know he
was doing the steak but she was just
they're still there like record him
that's my brother you know what I'm
saying do you remember when when um she
she battled Monica in The Boy Is Mine
yeah and then when she did that music
everyone was like oh my God
that's crazy they're like fighting on a
music video over a guy
you remember that was the concept yeah
that was crazy though I was more
mind-blown by Usher and an eye patch
during nice and slow whipping the [ __ ]
out of everybody with an exploding
suitcase
the storyline we don't really talk about
the stories old school music videos like
that we were wrong I know and they
started doing the thing where like in
the middle of the music video a sketch
would happen oh yeah and then they go
back to the song oh they don't do that
anymore no they don't but you know what
who did it the best is R Kelly with
Trapped in the Closet dude that that was
the bad you're gonna say your favorite
MJ but that works too I did it really
well too yeah he was the innovator but
like I'm talking about the 90s R B's but
R Kelly elevated it he took it
all story yes I'm ready I'm ready for a
troll version of all this like I want I
wish they did Top Gun too starring
Michael B Jordan as Tom Cruise's
character Maverick and they just played
it straight where it's like he in like
Maverick how long has it been he's like
he's like a sequel replacement yeah yeah
not even a remake a sequel It's like
changing yeah and they never address
anything
piss everyone the [ __ ] off with this
[ __ ] and it's like Maverick hey mad we
used to work together a long time you
know Great Balls of Fire and he's like a
[ __ ] 29 year old black dude dude
that's that's good they don't mention it
that's almost what happened with
Breaking Bad El Camino movie oh really
there's a character in El Camino who got
so fat since like and since breaking bad
he's that one like sociopath blonde guy
that keeps Jesse in the jail yeah right
he's getting shitloads and they don't
address like that how he looks
completely different it looks like a
totally different guy
yeah I got him yeah
Clemens got stung by a bees huh it's
pretty good
but overall I think the live actions are
you know again they're not for Our
Generation but in a sense they are
they're almost for our generation and
our children it's a corporate it's a
corporate cash in just like when we go
to Disneyland itself I don't know why
everyone gets so surprised like I can't
believe Disney's [ __ ] corporate
cashing in here and so you go to Disney
and they literally you go you walk
through the door and they [ __ ] attack
you yeah like you can't get away from it
plus it's like it's meant for us to
complain about that's part of the market
we're [ __ ] suckers you know what I
mean not me dude I spend so well because
your kid's gonna ask for it whether you
like it or not you know Disneyland is a
really good place to steal stuff from
all right guys it's on the video
foreign
[Music]